when I graduated college me and Joe
didn't really know what we're going to
do do we pursue YouTube we're at the
time AdSense was making like 300 bucks a
month Geo was already working at the
bank she told me you can pursue whatever
you want and I'll support you and what
the future might look like you weren't
even married that was just dating I was
just dating yeah yeah her parents are
together so they have one house and then
they have four kids so if their parents
pass probably gonna sell the house and
liquidate right I have two parents
they're divorced they both own each
house I'm the one kid so I'm gonna be
someone that inherits two houses she was
like way early on she was like Hey if
you want to sign a prenup or something
like that like I'd be totally down
because I get it your parents work hard
from a divorce to have their own two
houses I was like you're pretty [__]
dope dude that's pretty nice I should
marry her again what's the opposite of a
gold digger yeah yeah if one day I get
set on fire always paralyzed whatever it
could happen she could have everything
well always just take care of each other
and each other's families no matter what
yeah it's real [__] yeah like the
medieval ways you know